Mohammed is with us in Chicago
hi Mohammed how are you I'm good Dave
are you better than I deserve sir how
can I help
all right so a little bit of backstory
I'm 16 and I've worked all summer too
you know to try buy a car I've always
wanted I would be paying in you know all
cash and I wanted to ask if I should be
slapped for having such a dumb idea to
spend every penny of sending up yacht or
I should save it for something else or
put it maybe in a raw as I just want to
know you know where I should go with
this how much money are we talking about
um about fifteen or sixteen thousand
good for you very well thank you thank
you it's a very nice car for 16 years
old yeah I've worked a lot you know I
don't think she's gotten like a day it's
not easier I don't think I've gotten
like a day in like three or four years
without just thinking about it and how
great it would be but so what's the
dream car
it's a bmw m3
it's an e46 one so and how you gonna
maintain that puppy because your
maintenance on that's pretty serious
yeah continuing to work you know what I
hear from other owners is that cost
about on average 1,500 to 2,000 a year
to just keep it in good shape and
maintain it and you know I'm thankful
that my job right now um
can pay me enough to to you know
continue to fund it well you picked out
a very cool car no question about it and
way cool for 16 years old no question so
it's a fabulous automobile it really is
it typically is going to be a car though
by someone who has a really really good
income in the $1500 to keep it running
every year is a minor part of their
world instead of like a hundred percent
of your income you know it's 1,500 bucks
is a big part of your world a year it's
not a hundred percent of your income but
I mean it's a big part of your world is
16 years old
and you know I'm more concerned about
that ongoing maintenance cost of this
thing than I am the actual purchase oh
well I didn't mess and I make about you
know eighteen thousand a year right now
that really doesn't change it there
either yeah it doesn't change it I mean
a fifteen hundred dollar maintenance fee
for you know to keep a car running and
that's if everything goes pretty good
you can drop five grand in it pretty
quick on a beamer and again the car
you're talking about it's a beast of a
car it's a wonderful car I'm a car guy I
get why you'd want it the and and if you
want spend fifteen thousand dollars on a
car and you work this able to fifteen
thousand dollars and you do it I you
know I might say well might spend ten
and keep five in the bank that kind of
runs through my head but but aside from
that that doesn't bother me near as much
as you're signing up for a problem child
as far as maintenance goes I mean that's
what you're signing up for that bothers
me so as long as you know what you're
getting into and you're willing to take
it on but you may look up one day and go
I wish I didn't own this car and which
time you sell the car okay don't let
your dream turn into a nightmare so buy
it if you like it drive it a while and
if it starts to be a you know a drain on
the old wallet and it's more you know
you just like every time I look up I
don't know write checks for this thing
which is true of a car of that type you
are gonna write some checks for you know
a car of that type no question about it
and so I mean fifteen hundred's the
average you could write five thousand or
you could write five hundred
it's not gonna be fifteen hundred it's
not that's not what it's gonna work out
to be so be ready that's what's really
going to happen and if it gets to be a
burden to run sell a stupid thing you
know any debt on it you're paying cash
for it it's what your dream was you work
for it ring the bell hit the goal do it
if it doesn't work out sell it but be
emotionally ready to sell it if it
becomes a burden because I don't think
that writing those maintenance checks is
gonna be as fun or as easy as you're
acting like it's gonna be that's my
opinion I think I'd probably go ahead
and do it though you work for it you got
the money pay cash for it do it ding
ding hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button
to get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]